I thought it sounds good a guy remember
so you don't have to
[Music]
you
this is the shit so start off like a
copter when singing down years ago
[Music]
[Applause]
you
[Music]
hey everybody I'm Walter Brennan and
this is top five but no regular top five
this is the top five s nostalgia critic
episodes in honor of his ten year
anniversary and I didn't even put this
list together you guys did over 19,000
of you guys voted for your favorite
nostalgia critic episode over the past
week and we're going to count down the
top five that got the most votes right
here right now let's cut the BS let's
get into it number five
[Music]
you know I saw that movie when I was a
little kid and I remember everyone
saying it's so scary it's so creepy and
I was ready for it I guess I was a
little too ready because I didn't find
creepy at all
ie extra photos whole areas one half of
it's great the other half is a flaming
dumpster fire I just remember getting
through the movie was tough we like this
the part what the kids is great as a
legitimately great movie and we really
like Tim Curry he's the best thing in
the movie apart from that all I remember
sticking out was the scene where the
woman comes in and their husbands like
committed suicide in the bathtub and
it's just like crazy overacting and we
just walked it we were like laughing for
10 minutes I think we just decided
spontaneously there we were going to
some house in the review
[Music]
[Applause]
that was one of the first ones where I
got two really insanely overact which is
all I know how to do so
my governor is that hello friends I
invite Aviva Vickerman boy when you saw
her run down listless he pop out at
parties are you appropriate if I used
real alcohol I'd be dead
so I think that was just apple juice I
got that from lost in translation it was
kind of nice sucking out the poison from
what everyone said was like the scariest
thing a gamma fraid of clowns and made a
thing Stephen King was like the greatest
writer ever and he was singing King will
tell you he's not the greatest writer
ever even he's like yeah I'm okay so it
was nice to do that it was nice to show
people that something that really
terrified them as kids is actually kind
of funny is actually kind of silly and
it's fun to go back and see that because
so many people did not want to go back
and see it but when they saw here's this
review and it's really funny of I think
that sort of helps them look at a
different point of view so now they can
watch it and enjoy it but so the same
reason I watch it and enjoy it cuz it's
really funny ah ha ha
I dropped the but this was Roger ah ha
Wow alright look scary we got Jim jr. on
is here what's going on Jim hain unless
yeah everything yeah I wanted to ask you
could you've been a part of Masada
critic for so long what are some of the
the favorite props that you have made
for the show well definitely all the
props for the man master he was was a
big one I would say that I would have
built that stuff even if we didn't do
the review right when it's all done
we've been like that's the stuff I have
to make so that was a blast I was a ton
of fun and we probably had the most
amount of time to build that stuff to so
I could put a little bit more effort
into it but yeah
so you back cool so we got number four
come I want you to intro that for us
here comes number four
[Music]
honestly my opinion hasn't changed as we
did the review but when we did the
review my opinion to change because
originally I thought it was distressed
and then when we did the review I
thought oh it's hilarious trash and
that's pretty much where I'm at right
now
Arnold Schwarzenegger is would
definitely the funniest thing in it and
I find the movie legitimately funny but
I'm not sure it was always intentionally
meant to be funny and like because there
are some things that are just funny to
me like when she sneaks into the Batcave
and Alfred pops up and it's just like
and I took the liberty of making you
with suits the measurements of to your
specifications and I'm like how or why
did Alfred know what her exact
measurements were like just you enter
Joel Schumacher director of the third
Batman film Batman Forever it was the
Batman film studios always whining they
said marketable and as you would imagine
it was a big hit so logically Schumacher
was called in to direct the next one I
feel like he's in the wrong field I
think you should be a production
designer because he's always more
interested in what the sets they're
doing than any of the actors so but I
you know and he seems like a nice guy
and he apologized for Batman and Robin
I'm not gonna sit here and spend the
rest of my days claiming he destroyed
superhero movies as we know because
let's tell you they're doing just fine
super cross oh fuck oh Christmas be our
bullshit originally I think was for why
I did the Ninja Turtles movie movies I
was asking for a word to describe Ninja
Turtles 3 I couldn't think of one so I
asked Rob I was thinking of something
that could almost sound like a real word
and he software-wise like okay I got it
super crappy fucker if ik XP I love
bullshit
I said that's amazing that's totally not
what I'm looking for I came up with
horrible fuckers I'm going to use that
but I said but I love this we got to use
it for something else and then when
Batman Robin came around I'm like well
this you got to end on a song because
that's what Schumacher would do if he
could put it in the Batman movie
without a bat credit card they gave him
a bat credit card but that credit card
was pretty much my reaction when I saw
the movie I and I renew the movie was
going to be bad but we're like it's that
man we got to see it and that really was
the moment we're just like Batman was
kind of dead for like a couple seconds
they're like you know every when you're
a kid and you grew up with the Burton
Batman's and suddenly that credit card
pops up it's like Schumacher just came
out just stab your heart once and you
you survive and you got over it really
fast but it's still stabbed in the heart
so yeah and now I think it's I think
it's kind of funny no it's stupid it is
a lot of it movie is actually very funny
and how dumb it is they had the balls to
give one of the greatest superheroes of
all time a bet credit card no no there's
never been a convention I've gone
through where someone hasn't shouted it
loves it by the way when you do that at
conventions if you want to just see Doug
have the greatest time ever give him a
bad credit card and expect him to do the
whole routine just he loves it I
actually really like going over the top
screaming and yelling and choking and
chasing him dally I do all sorts of
various things and they love it too it's
all the few times you'll hear someone
say I love being beaten but as I get
older and I've lost my voice a lot and
stuff and energy don't get drained a
little bit now it's and people ask you
like a times at a convention I kind of
like I might do it once and then after
that I'll do like a Trier I fake punchy
like that too but it's like it's no
offense I just it takes a lot out of me
never stop I want somebody when we're 80
years old to show up at his funeral and
do it that review of Batman and Robin
was actually one of the first videos I
saw of a nostalgia critic so it's pretty
cool that you guys voted for it to be
number four on this list I mean that's
that credit card thing Jim let's get
back into the countdown it's number
three
I always wanted to do something with
friends Oh fly that's kind of how it
came about and I always want to do move
on Roo because that was kind of like it
everybody loved this movie and it always
kind of surprised me how nobody could
see the flaws in it or just how glaring
their words so I want to do this review
but I there are things I like in the
lumbers I do kind of like you know parts
of the style and everything so I want to
do this really really big review because
there's only so long you can yell in
front of a white wall so you could kind
of argue that the first like sort of the
New Wave overviews I did like after the
resurgence because now a lot of the
reviews are like that they're more
production
I wanted a review to feel like a
production because you're doing video
reviews and if you're going to just sit
in front of a camera and talk and give
your opinion you can't go well why
wasn't this written you get a little bit
of the facial expressions and stuff but
you want to do something different with
it you want to do comedy you want to do
like a story you want to add music you
want to do everything you can't do with
a written review so that was my first
real attempt in my opinion like really
pushing dancing what can I do with this
and and it was a lot of fun it was a lot
worse but it was definitely a lot of fun
guilty pleasures and anytime guilty
pleasures you have your things I have my
guilty pleasures munna rooted bullshit
guilty pleasure
well we won't come on
[Music]
and that's the first one that we
actually did you know a big blowout you
know later it turned into phantom and
lame is and stuff like that but the
Moulin Rouge was a lot of fun because we
try it the first time we decomposed
music which is what we tend to do here
it's one of the things where I would
sort of say here's what I'm looking to
do in the song and here's the song it's
satirizing go to work friend and then
with the last one I said I think I can
write this one have a good idea what to
do with this one so I wrote the lyrics
gave to my dad said I have this melody
but I don't know if it works you see if
you can make it work that that's kind of
what he does and yeah I wouldn't know
that would later be the theme song by
actually think it's a good thing
[Music]
Oh
there's just fun working with these guys
and making this music almost the real
thing and in some cases probably better
than a lot of you guys seem to really
like those musical reviews and Moulin
Rouge is definitely a very strong
episode of nostalgia critic but now
we're getting down to the nitty gritty
the top 2 there weren't too many votes
in between these two ones so they're
pretty close but this is the one that
you guys voted for as the second best
nostalgia critic episode
[Music]
everyone wanted me to see this movie to
talk about it and I said they haven't
seen that I haven't seen the show so
everyone want me to see the show and
talk about it so I'm like okay if I'm
going to do this this was the first time
we started doing show view logs so I
would watch an episode and just get my
thoughts real fast just thinking like
okay a little something you know just to
pad out views or something like that
they say really well like the show has
such a following and you can see why
it's a wonderful show so I wanted to go
into the movie even though I could go in
totally blind and just judge as a movie
I wanted to go in with an idea of the
show because I felt like everyone
thought I could about the show so much
and so finally it kind of deserved that
so I think that need to review a lot
funnier too because then I could do sad
times in the show I could do old modules
to the show I could compare them I could
show even more outside of just being the
movie what kind of a heinous crime
against the show it really was so I
think that made it a lot more interest
and give a lot more interesting points
of view it's really really awful the
problem with it it's not so much that
legitimately the worst thing ever made
that we've had to sit through is that
it's so harnesses what is a great show
and anyone who got introduced to that
movie first before the cartoon show
completely lost out so I hate it more
for that reason if you can't be the
obvious similarities between the movies
designs in the show's design clearly
that you have a drink enough cactus
juice I mean gosh can you guys imagine
constantly misrepresenting characters by
constantly getting their skin colors
wrong shameful unforgivable atrocious it
was fun working with Rachael and when I
read the script I saw that we would be
playing parodies of characters in the
actual show which you know I thought was
going to be a lot of fun and it was
because lavender Last Airbender it was
very interesting cartoon there was
nothing quite on TV at the time that I
can recall
so getting the play like silca it
it was a lot of fun are you sure we have
a right guy
we didn't have like quite as much
costume stuff here at the time I was
still kind of moving stuff in and
acquiring different costumes and
materials and bringing props it and
stuff like that so I think the costumes
were all made out of an old bedsheet
that I had it's like that blue color or
whatever I just cut up and made those
like tunics and stuff and then the
little like ponytail things with Malcolm
I just like cut the tip off a wig now
the most difficult thing was actually
trying to get it to stay in his hair but
then he I will and then creating the the
shovel on mask
actually I made that Doug came with a
mask he had picked it up and we were
shooting or doing the one of the charity
events at that time so I was just kind
of fit in the background and small the
charity event was going on doing all the
different catchphrases and stuff like
that and painting with the mask it's
cool because it's again you kind have an
idea what the character is going to look
like and you hope it's going to look as
good as you wanted to because I sort
give an idea and I hand it over to Jim
on my dad and sometimes they're bringing
other people too and when they get it
looking like just perfect exactly what
you're looking for there's always kind
of chill like yes like this will work
this will work and that's kind of what I
got with that and then Y heard rob boys
they see Malcolm sir doing the
mannerisms to Rob's voice which i think
is always great it's just a little off
so Ken reminds me of the boss from
Seinfeld the one that's obviously dubbed
there's no reason it's just funny it's
just that extra little bit of surreal
news I think it's a giggle so yeah he
always get the giggle out of me I just
think it's always great and for a
certain as a jerk who might be listening
I have only this to say stand down no
critic has ever been able to stop me
before if you do not I will suck out
what little talent you had to begin with
Shyamalan is one of my all-time favorite
characters in anything he's a team
effort
I do the pantomime and I do the body
work I'm in the outfit and is actually
Rob's boys
so in Legend of Korra Steve Blum who's
like one of my voice acting heroes and
Malcolm soo we had to fight over who was
good so he did this character named Amon
so Doug just decided we're going to come
up with shaman as this character but
since nobody looks exactly like
Shyamalan we're just going to do it as a
mod and then this I know it's one a few
times where I like just pulled rank
again someone else because I was like I
want to do the voice is like well
Malcolm does it to him like I don't care
there's the one time I'm totally
stepping over Malcolm to do something
yeah
great he's been Shama mised hi guys
I just wanna stand directly in the
middle of the shot and stare blankly
into the camera this does before and
this is a man forgetting satellite I
guess downlights okay
hi I'm Doug Walker hi I'm Rob Walker
what I feel like that's me every day
enjoy your incredibly awesome show and
enjoy hating your incredibly awesome
[Music]
what are your whatever the movie whether
it's good or bad I want to see every
Shyamalan movie ever so take that for
what it's worth but we got Tamra
chambers here what's going on camera hi
guys hey I wanted to ask you what were
some of your favorite episodes of
Mustapha critic over these past 10 years
and what were some of the favorite
characters of youth play person I always
loved being in the Star Wars Episode
those are so much fun to do and the
episodes that bring everyone in is more
of an ensemble is a lot of fun
Mad Max was really great I felt very bad
after that
Wonder Woman kind of helped me
rediscover my love of DC and I just
loved playing her but my favorite of all
time has to be hyper fan girl she's my
favorite didn't I really identify with
her well a lot of you guys voted over
19,000 of you for your favorite
nostalgia critic episode and I wanted to
at least give a shout out to some of the
ones that didn't make the top 5 there
was one that just barely missed out on
this top 5 so number 6 through 10 here
they are right now as honorable mention
[Music]
we got Rob and Barney Walker here Wow
legends in front of them what are some
of your favorite episode we saw the
critic over the past 10 years shimmy
with Gollum shortly by Matt Matt yet I
like Schindler's List followed by
Citizen Kane we didn't do Citizen Kane
I thought we we didn't do Citizen Kane
and while in excellence in that case
I've got to say hocus pocus because I
love doing the makeup and the costumes
for Doug by the way those were his real
teeth those are not safe Doug makes a
very handsome businessman but we're
getting to number one now thousands of
people voted for their favorite massage
it for this episode I introduced it for
all right coming up magic number 1214
know how many are there
you're fine there's number six all right
number five four four three two one
here it is got it wrong again
I got a ton of requests to review this
movie I knew it was at the time out kind
of a newer movie oh ok so several years
old but and I had no idea about I just
kept seeing these people once a while
would say review the room review the
room and it was enough I said okay well
somebody will watch this if anything
even not that many people know about it
sounds like something where if I do talk
about it
it'll get it attention so I went in
knowing not a thing about it and as soon
as Tommy walks and says hi babe I mean
it's just immediately your soul you
can't believe that's going to be the
main character that's your lead and he
came and say two words convincingly
there one syllable each two words hi
babe and he couldn't do it and you just
know you're in for the strangest ride
mr. Z at would of our time I don't know
what like it was the perfect amount of
so bad it's kind of amazing it's not
even really like it's not even in my top
34 the worst things I've had to sit
there because it's so awful in the right
ways it's probably like Batman and Robin
I'm just like no x-ray I could watch
this multiple times that we get a good
laugh out of it you're part of my life
do you know everything I could not go on
without you Lisa
no it actually was a little hard to get
material because you make your initial
jokes like he has that act and he has
that way of talking he makes these
choices throughout the whole thing
there's only so many ways you can make
fun of that but it's so consistent so
you really have to start thinking
outside the box that there's just so
much bad being thrown at you that you
can't always address at all
[Applause]
that was one of the earliest ones that
when I made that that seahorse City or
whatever like I was kind of amazed how
well that actually turned out and Doug
was like really happy whatever it was I
was like okay great
I fooled them all hahahahaha absolutely
I mean it was like a fever dream I had
actually where that's why it's so close
to my actual vision of what the horrible
but that's not for years to come
where'd you hear that I mean I just not
said you know anyone would you know if
there was you know this will be the
salute but um absolutely anyway how is
your sex life can't talk about it why
not why not have I just brought it the
fuck I don't know where you weird alien
ma'am for me he's the perfect definition
of frenemy because there are there are
things I admire about him and there's
things I clearly do not admire about him
and I think anyone that gets to know him
so it comes across those same elements
but even with that said there's things
you still admire about him and and it's
just this constant back and forth and
again I think that's the fascination I
think if he just turned over a new leaf
and was like oh now he's always nice
he's always kind he's always he always
makes sense you know he finishes
sentences and stuff like that in a
strange way he wouldn't be as
interesting
so even though like the problems he's
kind of put it through he sent a
cease-and-desist he's got no strikes on
our channel he's you know talked bad
stuff about all that stuff in a strange
way I still don't know looking back if I
would change it because it still adds to
just some mystery of what he is this mad
sort of crazy I'm not going to say
geniuses
that's not true but you know it was just
an interesting individual
you have taemi partly shocked oh my god
even when all that stuff was going on
with the cease-and-desist and the
strikes and and all that stuff I still
recommend the room like it has to be
seen to be believed
it's one of the most entertaining zombie
movies of all time it needs to be
experienced it's a nun thing you will
come up better for it you will come up
change I will throw it out there too
many of the cast members have been
unbelievable to us about particularly
Gregg's of Sarah even one of the guys
that says like Cartoon Network and us
are like two of the biggest forces that
got like just this wide range of fans
you know to notice them so yeah I mean
really for all you can say about Tommy
it has opened up just as incredible new
experience and just meeting incredible
people so no I wouldn't give it up or
anything well that's it over 19,000 of
you guys voted thank you so much for
voting for your best and saw the critic
episode there's going to be more stuff
to come so make sure you come back next
week on top 5 and it's been 10 years and
this other critics celebrate do whatever
you want to do go on tumblr and post a
bunch of gifts like to comment on the
video whatever you want to do but thank
you so much for voting thank you for
watching and we'll see you next time
hello I'm the Nostalgia Critic man ten
long years as crazy we are going to cut
out the top 5 best of these episodes
right we keep it's over it's over yeah
well what was the number one the room
it wasn't alien 3 no you didn't do
anything 3 you mean I shaved my head for
nothing whatever at least Schindler's
List is on there right you can watch
[Music]
you